as outlandish as he was in the ring
macho man randy savage was very
different in his personal life he was
just as passionate but many recalled a
more reserved and sometimes even
paranoid man
here are some of the more tragic details
from the life of macho man
randy savage wrestling is entirely about
cooperative storytelling but that
doesn't mean
wrestlers themselves have to get along
many of the best matches have been
between
people who despised each other well
beyond the normal face
heel dynamic savage had the misfortune
of getting on the bad side of one of the
biggest wrestling attractions of all
time
andre the giant andre was noted for
being especially aggressive with savage
throwing him around the ring and pulling
at his hair two reasons have been given
for andre's animosity towards
savage the first is macho's extensive
use of baby oil which helps muscled
wrestlers stand out but also makes them
hard to grapple
savage's brother lanny poppo told the
tampa bay times
andre hated baby oil but randy wouldn't
stop wearing it he stubbornly said
andre's gimmick is being a giant and
mine is baby oil he never backed down
from andre
and they never got along because of it
the second as recounted by andre's
daughter
was his zero tolerance policy for
steroids and once he found out that the
macho man stayed macho by using them
that was it randy savage was a second
generation wrestler
his father angelo paffo was popular both
as a face and heel
during the 1950s through the early 80s
from 1978 to 1984
he ran international championship
wrestling out of kentucky
it was one of the most prominent
so-called outlaw promotions one that
existed outside the influence of the
national wrestling alliance
he had a dedicated following throughout
his career especially among
older fans and the wrestlers themselves
savage
idolized his father both as a wrestler
and as a man any perceived slight
towards angelo was taken personally this
included one by vince mcmahon and the
federation
that macho man never got over the wwf
planned an old-timers battle royal for a
house show at the meadowlands
in new jersey for november of 1987.
randy savage was at the peak of his
power in the company
he just formed the mega powers with hulk
hogan that october
and had an all-time classic match with
ricky steamboat at wrestlemania 3
earlier in the year as such savage
flexed his political muscles to get his
father into the match
the day of the match came and plenty of
legends were part of it but
no angelo poppo lanny poppo told
bleacher report
randy really loved vince until the
battle royal he felt really bad when al
costello who was one of dad's best
friends in wrestling
said where's your father he should be
here randy never forgot about the battle
royal
he felt guilty like he should have done
more the battle royal snub
was the beginning of the end of savage's
relationship with vince mcmahon by 1994
savage was spending more time as an
announcer than a wrestler he was just
past
40 years old but still felt he could
compete lanny poppo recalled the
bleacher report that his brother
felt he never had a match as good as the
steamboat match but thought he could
recapture that magic with sean michaels
randy wanted to do a two-year program
building up to a match with sean at
wrestlemania randy would lose
retire and go back to the announcer's
table this proposal was shot down
since the federation was in the middle
of a youth movement savage decided to
take his talents elsewhere when his
contract expired which in that
era meant the competing world
championship wrestling
even so breaking off his decade-plus
relationship with vince was daunting
bruce prichard who was vince's right
hand man in that era revealed on his
podcast something to wrestle that randy
had to get drunk
to call vince and tell him he was
quitting only for an irritated benz to
call him back the next day
the two did indeed talk the next day
when savage made it clear he was gone
the wwf never referenced talent leaving
much less going to other companies
but mcmahon broke his own protocol and
offered savage and emotional goodbye
on commentary the next week this velvet
divorce did not stay
so civil backstage when macho man left
for wcw
he took his slim gym sponsorship with
him often reported as a million dollar
deal
attempts to transfer the sponsorship to
wwf star bam bam bigelow did not go
through
and wcw reaped the benefits while vince
had another reason to dislike savage
gotta hear a beef cutting of spice new
excitement
snap into a slim jim oh yeah
it's almost impossible to talk about
randy savage without bringing up miss
elizabeth his on-screen manager and wife
miss elizabeth whose real name was
elizabeth ann hewlett
was married to macho man for seven years
in secret
before their iconic wedding at
summerslam 1991.
she was especially notable for her role
in causing the mega powers to explode
after savage got paranoid that his
friend hulk hogan
had lust in his eyes for elizabeth
savage was as protective of elizabeth
outside the ring
as he was in it he made decisions about
how she'd dress and behave in the ring
all to avoid embarrassing her several
wrestlers traveled with their wives
and savage wanted to protect her from
the cutthroat cruelty of the other
wrestlers
especially since she was a performer
herself even with noble intentions
this was a smothering relationship lanny
poffo said much in liz's relationship
during the wedding was tumultuous
on the verge of breaking up the
relationship reached its low point in
1992
when hogan was shooting mr nanny liz and
hogan's wife linda were close friends
and liz begrudgingly got permission to
visit the hogans
and help out while the hulkster was
working savage tried to call her but
couldn't get a hold of her because
she was in another room in a jealous
rage savage flew down to florida the
next day
and retrieved his wife liz left savage a
few weeks later
which left the wrestler emotionally
devastated even after they divorced
savage cared about her enough to get her
a job in wcw
in the mid to late 1980s macho man randy
savage and hulk hogan were the two
biggest stars in the wrestling business
the two were also
for a time great friends during the dark
side of the ring
episode a match made in heaven linda
hogan said that their families often
held cookouts and went over
in-ring choreography this all fell apart
after the incident in florida
savage in his paranoia blamed hogan for
liz leaving
jimmy hart said of savage going to
florida to retrieve liz
that was the beginning of the end for
them but the beginning of the end for
randy and hulk
too because randy always thought hulk
had something to do with it
i've been with hulk for 39 years hulk
had nothing to do with that he was
shooting the movie
hogan and savage reunited on a
professional basis in wcw
even if savage spent most of his time
there as a second banana to hollywood
hogan
savage held much animosity towards hogan
during this time
which seldom got attention over the
dozens of other train wrecks associated
with wcw
hogan claimed to wwe.com that he and
savage met by chance at a doctor's
office a few months before savage's
death
and they reconciled wrestlers getting
injured is nothing new
nor is taking lasting damage from their
work even so
savage was widely regarded as a safe
worker
and seldom suffered any high profile
in-ring
injuries instead the injury that caused
him the most
lasting damage happened on a movie set
playing bone saw mcgraw
in sam raimi's first spider-man movie
it's one of the most iconic scenes in
any superhero movie one made especially
hilarious by implying that
wrestling is an actual competitive sport
[Applause]
it's also the source of damage that
lasted him until his dying day
the 50 year old macho man insisted on
doing all of his own stunts in the scene
this included a spot at the end when
bonesaw gets monkey-flipped onto his
head
the spot required multiple takes and
took a toll on the aging wrestler
lanny poppo told bleacher report that he
needed a lot of physical therapy but he
was never the same
instead of turning his neck to see you
he turned his torso
randy savage's last wrestling appearance
came in the final months of 2004
when a grizzled macho man appeared
during the early days of tna
his surprise entrance at the first ever
victory road pay-per-view
saw him confront jeff jarrett and
remains one of the most
memorable moments from that era the
follow-up was less so
he stuck around for a month was part of
a six-man tag match at turning point
nobody remembers
and then left the company after
disagreements over booking many look
back
on savage's brief tna run as a
disappointment those behind the scenes
tell an even sadder story in the genesis
of tna
an ebook about the early days of the
company agent bill behrens in particular
described savage as a headache to deal
with
and frequently sauced out of his mind a
few people connected with the company
had a big trailer
one that became a hot spot for
dysfunctional stars who wanted to sit
around drinking all day
barons recalled randy was one of the
guys that did that
so his run was bad all the way around it
made it clear that there wasn't going to
be a good final run that randy savage
would have in wrestling
angelo paffo lived until the age of 84
dying about a month shy of what would
have been his 85th birthday
savage also had to deal with an issue
most everyone does with parents lucky
enough to get old
age catching up to them angelo in
particular
suffered from dementia with his
functions failing notably by 2009
savage went to great lengths to care for
his ailing father
going so far as to install an invalid
toilet and a walk-in bathtub in his
father's house
angelo died march of 2010. randy told
the st
petersburg times he has always been my
hero and my mentor
and the priceless gifts he gave i will
have and cherish forever
a mere two months later savage got
married a sad milestone for his father
to miss
randy savage woke up on may 20th 2011
not feeling all that well his wife lynn
figured he might just need something to
eat
so they went out to breakfast on the way
back he lost consciousness
with his foot slamming on the
accelerator the car passed off the
cement median into oncoming traffic
and lynn quickly grabbed the wheel and
swerved the car into a tree
she escaped with minor injuries but
savage was declared dead
later that day the autopsy showed that
savage died of a heart attack
from ventricular fibrillation the death
was likely quick and painless
even if it occurred at the most
dangerous possible time
casting a long shadow over his cause of
death is savage's
alleged predilection for steroids heart
disease connected to drug use has
claimed
many lives far too young in the
wrestling business while it's hard to
say for sure that savage's death was a
direct result
it's hard not to connect those dots it
took randy savage
entirely too long to get into the wwe
hall of fame
he was the crown jewel of the class of
2015
and occasion made all the more tragic by
the fact that it was posthumous
part of the delay might have been some
of that indeterminate heat backstage
but a bigger part was savage's own
wishes after the vanerex were inducted
into the wwe hall of fame as a family in
2009
macho man randy savage declared that wwe
would have to take his whole family in
as well
if they wanted him this was of course
unlikely
angelo was more of a star in the
territories than any wwe related
property
and lanny's run as the genius was
successful and well regarded
but not exactly hall of fame worthy
lanny honored this wish
after macho man's passing in 2015
however
lanny relented he told sporting news i
had an epiphany when i was 59 years old
in that
i'm the older brother now now i get to
make unpopular decisions
i'm not a star trek fanatic but the
needs of the many far outweigh the needs
of the few or the one
randy loved the fans and so do i and
randy not being in the hall of fame was
a horrible thing to do to his fans
lanny himself was the one who inducted
his brother
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite athletes and pop culture
icons are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one